[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans filcho ce
numéro est consacré à l'aéronautique
dans le département les ivelines
attirent d'une part les grands groupe
comme ADS et sa filiale spatiale Astrium
basé au Murau qui développe notamment la
fusée Ariane nous irons d'ailleurs à
leur rencontre et puis d'autre part les
étudiants comme l'ESTACA cette école
d'ingénieur historique qui va quitter
Paris en 2015 pour s'installer à Montini
le Bretonneux mais pour commencer on
fait un point global avec vous Yv
vanandeval bonjour bonjour vous êtes
vice-président du Conseil général des
Yvelines délégué notamment au
développement économique et à l'emploi
alors parlez-nous un petit peu de ce
tissu que représente l'aéronautique dans
le département quels grands groupes sont
présents l'aéronautique occupe une place
très importante dans l'économie du
département puisque on y compte pas
moins de 14 grands établissements à peu
près 200 petites entreprises 200 PME et
c'est près de 5000 emplois pratiquement
tous les grands groupes sont présents
EADS mais sont également présents dasso
Tales le groupe Safran toutes les
grandes enseignes si je puis dire toutes
les grandes entreprises françaises sont
présentes ici vous disez ça représente
environ 5000 emplois dans le département
donc c'est assez
pour pour une économie au niveau local
mais ce n'est pas nouveau les ivelines
ont toujours attiré l'aéronautique et
l'aviation historiquement oui c'est
l'aéronautique a pris son son envol
sonans mauvais jeun mot dans les
ivelines à la fin des années
190010 par à peu près parce que les
constructeurs étaient dans la proche
banlieu de Paris et ils avaient besoin
de terrain et à l'époque il y avait de
l'espace libre dans les ivelines des
grands plateaux et les plateformes
d'essaiis se sont installées à bu avec
blerio se sont installés à toussul noble
avec Farman se sont installés à véisie
et c'est ainsi que progressivement
l'aéronautique s'est implanté dans les
ivelines comme le site d'Astrium au
Murau qui vient de fêter ses 100 ans
exactement les Mureaux avaient un
avantage supplémentaire c'est qu'on
était au bord de la Sene et qu'à
l'époque la France faisait encore des
hydravions et donc c'était un site idéal
on avait à la fois un plateau une grande
plaine au bord de la scène et Laib de
faire naviguer et de faire décoller les
hydravions donc les grands groupes
s'installent ensuite au fur et à mesure
on parlait de ADS tals et puis des PME
vont profiter aussi de ces installations
toutes ces grandes entreprises ont
besoin soit de sous-traitants soit de
fournisseurs certains sont directement
liés aux entreprises d'autres sont
indépendants mais on a des entreprises
importantes comme Bertin on a Pirro
alliance une petite entreprise mais très
spécialisé puisqu'elle fabrique les
boulons explosifs qui servent à la
séparation
soit des éléments de lanceur soit des
satellites merci beaucoup y veval pour
votre éclairage merci beaucoup on part
maintenant pour les Mureaux et Astrium à
la rencontre du directeur de
l'établissement dans les coulisses de la
fusée
Ariane nous voici à présent chez Astrium
au Mureau Astrium c'est la branche
spatiale du groupe EADS je suis avec
hugmont bonjour bonjour Alice vous êtes
directeur deette établissement et ici on
se trouve dans un endroit assez
particulier de ce site c'est le hall
Arian qui fait 37 m de hauteur on
pourrait y mettre l'arc de triomphhe
mais vous vous faites autre chose ici
tout à fait alors on est dans le hall
d'intégration du lanceur Aryan 5 donc
c'est dans ce hall où nous faisons
l'assemblage de l'étage principal du
lanceur avant de l'envoyer par la scène
sur courou où on fait comme tout le
monde le sait ou presque le lancement du
lanceur combien de lanceurs sont
fabriqués chaque année ici nous avons la
la capacité de se lanceurs par an tant
au niveau des doc d'intégration que sur
la réalisation proprement dite du
réservoir on imagine bien que ce sont
des projets d'envergure qui mobilisent
autant beaucoup d'investissements mais
aussi beaucoup d'hommes combien de
personnes travaillent ici sur ces
projets là alors sur le site des Mureaux
en général il y a 2500 emplois qui au
quotidien ben travaillent non seulement
sur les activités d'Aran 5 mais
également sur nos activités de
dissuasion sur les infrastructures
orbitales et des activités liées au
satellite puisque nous faisons également
des sous-ensembles de satellites doncon
appelle des tubes ou des réflecteurs en
matériaux composite et carbone parce que
pour bien comprendre donc cette fusée
aréienne en fait vous vous vous allez
produire ce lanceur mais au-dessus va
être ajouté le satellite qui sera
ensuite mis sur orbite et tout cela se
fait à courou la vocation déjà du
lanceur il est important de le rappeler
hein c'est pour mettre sur orbite des
charges utille ou des satellites hein et
donc c'est la même chose quand on parle
de charge utile ou de satellite et
c'estes charges utille sont donc sur la
partie haute du lanceur dans la coiffe
et dans cette coiffe c'est la
particularité de notre lanceur Aren 5
c'est nous pouvons y mettre deux charges
utiles ce qui permet de rentabiliser le
lancement et donc de pouvoir mettre deux
satellites sur enbit avec le même
lanceur quel est le profil des personnes
qui travaillent sur ce projets le profil
de nos collaborateurs bien sur le site
c'est 75 % d'ingénieurs et cadre puisque
nous réalisons mais nous développons
également puisque nous assurons la M
d'œuvre et nous sommes architectes
industriel du lanceur donc il nous faut
concevoir les lanceurs et c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous avons des des
compétences en ingénierie de lancement h
des compétences qui sont très précieuses
he on se rend bien compte qu'ici il y a
des choses qu'on dont on ne peut pas
parler déjà qu'on peut pas dire à la
caméra parce qu'elles sont secrètes on a
l'impression qu'il y a un savoir-faire
comment est-ce qu'on gère quand on est
directeur comme vous tout ce
savoir-faire toute cette technicité
secret c'est peut-être un grand mot hein
néanmoins il y a un certain nombre de de
de compétences et de technologies qu'on
que nous maîtrisons il y a effectivement
des choses sur lequelles aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui il y a une concurrence
importante bon on va éviter de tout
faire voir l'essentiel étant aussi
d'expliquer ce que nous faisons pour que
la majorité de la la grande population
puisse se rendre compte de l'intérêt de
nos activités et aussi de ce que nous
faisons au grand public h et comment ce
savoir-faire est façonné et créé c'est
ici que ça se passe aussi nous sommes
architectes industriel donc on conçoit
on développe et on réalise et le fait de
réaliser c'estàdire que nous avons tous
les moyens industriels sur
l'établissement donc de l'usinage des
pièces donc des tes primaires jusqu'à
l'intégration de l'étage principal et
toutes ces opérations se font sur
l'établissement avec des sous-ensembles
qui sont effectués dans différents
parties de l'Europe que nous assemblons
soit sur le site des Mureaux soit
directement en Guyane en fonction de la
capacité de réalisation et le fait
d'être dans les Yvelines est-ce que
c'est un département particulier irement
dynamique pour vous en terme de
recherche spatiale alors les ivelines
c'est important mais c'est aussi
historique puisque notre établissement à
100 ans nous avons fêté les 100 ans du
site cette année et nous avons effectué
des activités aéronautiques et
maintenant spatial depuis plusieurs
décennies et donc l'importance de notre
localisation elle tient ben à la
proximité des moyens de locomotion et
également de l'environnement industriel
nous avons un nos partenaires importants
pas très loin à Vernon qui est la snekma
mais également un tissu industriel
d'entreprise avec lequel nous
travaillons en partenariat sur
l'ensemble du département et de la
région Île-de-France on contribue
également au développement des jeunes
qui qui sont issus des Mureaux hein et
ce que nous faisons surtout c'est que
nous nous essayons de les aider à ce que
les leurs études se réalisent au mieux
donc on on participe à des bourses
d'études et à la sélection d'un certain
nombre de ces jeunes à travers justement
ces financements et on est également à
même de travailler avec les PME de la
région et notamment sur l'amélioration C
PME on a un projet qu'on a mené depuis
maintenant de 2010 et qui a abouti à
l'été 2012 qui un projet qui s'appelle
Comette sur un certain nombre de PME
pilotes il y avait 7 PME pilotes et nous
avons amené ces PME à évoluer en même
temps que nous sur les mêmes
technologies et on leur a apporté des
méthodes de qualité sur lequel on a
travaillé ensemble de façon à ce que
tous ensemble on progresse dans le même
sens quel est l'avenir pour Astrium on
pense notamment à Arian 5 évolution Aren
6 il avit une échéance importante que
nous avons vécu euh ces derniers jours
au mois de novembre dernier qui est la
ministérielle de l'Agence spatiale
européenne qui permet de décider sur les
grands programmes des années à venir là
en l'occurrence le l'évolution de notre
lanceur arien 5 actuel ce qu'on appelle
arien 5 évolution a été validé donc pour
les de années à venir donc c'est c'est
un lanceur qui va permettre de mettre
une charge utile de 2 tonnes
supplémentaires sur orbite donc qui est
important puisque la charge utile est
vraiment l'essentiel vous avez pu le
comprendre pour un lanceur et nous avons
également le lancement du nouveau
programme qui s'appelle Arian 6 et qui a
été décidé et pour lequel nous allons
effectivement contribuer au niveau
d'Astrium et donc le site va s'agrandir
alors le site a déjà anticipé puisque on
a fait l'acquisition de terrains
supplémentaires depuis quelques années
maintenant donc le site repose sur 90
hectares avec des installations que nous
mettons en place de façon à prévoir
l'avenir c'est toute la difficulté aussi
de nos activités il nous faut avoir des
programmes pour investir mais néanmoins
on commence à investir avant d'avoir des
programmes voyez ce sont des montants
assez importants depuis les qu dernières
années on a investi à peu près de
l'ordre de 120 millions d'euros sur
l'établissement en terme
d'infrastructure de de moyens industriel
également de système informatique est-ce
qu'il y a des concurrents sérieux sur
votre domaine on est sur un marché
concurrentiel déjà les pays actuellement
qui dispose de lanceur comme la Russie
les États-Unis plus des pays émergents
qui arrivent sur le marché donc c'est la
raison pour laquelle il nous faut
améliorer notre productivité être de
plus en plus conscient de de la
situation également économique générale
qui fait que nous devons avoir une
maîtrise de nos cûts le plus possible de
nouveaux projets ça veut dire aussi
peut-être des recrutements quelle est la
politique d'Astrium en terme
d'apprentissage de passation des savoirs
nous avons une politique de recrutement
qui effectivement est annuel mais depuis
les trois dernières années on a recruté
un peu plus de 400 principalement des
ingénieurs et cadres néanmoins
culturellement dans la société nous
utilisons également l'apprentissage
puisque la forme de compagnonnage est
aussi très important et euh au jour
d'aujourd'hui sur un site comme le nôtre
on a une 80 jeunes à peu près sous le
forme de l'apprentissage mais on est en
concurrence avec d'autres entreprises
donc on a la chance d'avoir des produits
qui font rêver ou du moins techniquement
aussi qui sont très intéressants et de
pouvoir apporter justement à
savoir-faire à ces jeunes qui ne manque
à apprendre merci beaucoup hé mon de
nous avoir ouvert les portes de votre
établissement merci à vous on le voit
bien les evveline attire autant des
entreprises mais aussi des étudiants et
l'école d'ingénieur lestaka qui forme
1500 ingénieurs par an qui est installé
pour l'instant dans le 92 viendra
s'installer à 50 ans en Eveline ce sera
en 2015 on écoute sa
[Musique]
directrice
les critères qui ont joué pour nous ça a
été à la fois le tissu économique local
c'est-à-dire le fait d'avoir à proximité
des entreprises un écosystème industriel
qui soit proche de notre cœur de
formation c'est-à-dire des entreprises
dans le domaine des transports et des
sites de Red EADS fait partie des
entreprises qui concourent à la
formation on travaille avec le knes on
travaille avec l' nérard ENF on a un
certain nombre de partenariats forts qui
permettent que nos étudiants aient accès
véritablement au savoir-faire de du
spatial
français c'est terminé pour ce numéro de
filcoo j'en profite pour vous souhaiter
d'excellentes fêtes de fin d'année je
vous retrouve vendredi 11 janvier pour
un nouveau
[Musique]
numéro